my boyfriend he lost his cousin about a  year ago and he was really really down I  couldn't even get him out of it but I  showed him your trash talk because he  used to do that as a hobby so I've been  showing him the trash talk videos and  he's been doing very very well with his  flipping stuff and he has passion he's  happy now and I want to thank you for  doing that for him thank you for saying  that yeah it's been very hard for us  because we're both doing something on  the side and we're both busy and before  you I couldn't get him out of that hole  so thank you thank you thank you so much  again thank you guys all for sharing  these nice stories it means the world to  me